the jurogan experience the putin thing
scares the [ __ ] out of me though because
he's uh
you know
when it comes to
warlords
he's a legitimate warlord yeah who is in
charge of i didn't know that they had
more nukes than us i mean i guess it's
kind of a moot point right because
everybody's gotta need yeah everybody's
got enough to kill everybody how many
times over yeah isn't it something crazy
like 10 times over yeah they did the
math and and it was it was in double
digits it's not good it's not it's not
good but it's look
if you if you step back everybody's
everybody's thinking okay how did this
you know how did this [ __ ] up
situation happen
well it's been building obviously right
i mean we have how much news coverage do
we have of well they're adding more
troops to the border with ukraine i
wonder what they're doing it could be
military exercises so there was a
tremendous amount of speculation
leading up to what the [ __ ] is going on
which in a sense points to how uh
lacking the intelligence is on
on putin on plans and intentions right
and he's he's like that's a heavy lift
right to come up with that sort of intel
because ideally you're gonna want a
human source
um
you know you can get again you can get
whatever you could you can gather
intelligence from a variety of sources
but you really want human access people
who can tell you you know what i had a
meeting with him and
boy i tell you what he was pissed off or
this is what he said or this is how he
looked
without that without knowing what plans
and intentions are or you know being
able to gather intel on say the command
staff
everybody was kind of speculating willie
won't he what's he going to do well
stepping back if you look at what he's
done
he's been pretty damn consistent right
over the years
and so i guess you know in a part
a lot of it was optimistic thinking okay
he just wants the eastern part of the
country he's just going to go in there
and take that because you know maybe
he's he's already got it he's declared
those two republics legit
maybe that's all he wants he's already
taken crimea
and so that i think that was optimistic
thinking hoping that you know the guy is
not going to lose his [ __ ] and go all
the way through the country well that's
what he's done and in part because again
if you look at what he did in chechnya
if you look at what he did helping assad
in syria if you look at what he did
annexing crimea if you look at georgia
abkhazia south of session
every step of the way
he's been following in his mind
this stated desire that he's made very
public over the years
to rebuild his sphere of influence
right so
in in part you could argue we kind of
missed the obvious right we didn't see
the obvious in front of us because we
were all kind of hoping and mirroring
our values on onto onto putin who
doesn't deserve to have our values
mirrored onto them because we're
thinking maybe maybe he just wants a
little bit maybe he's just trying to
make a point maybe he just wants them to
sign a charter saying they won't be part
of nato
so anyway uh i you know my point being
two-fold i guess we we missed the boat
on that we missed it in part because we
were always trying to be optimistic and
trying to think okay well maybe they
think like we do maybe there's a
rational process there and then part of
it is
intel was lacking and when it comes to
intel when you're talking about like
in-person intel
how difficult is that to get on a guy
like putin
it's really tough it's i mean that you
know look it's a it's a very heavy lift
the higher they go up the food chain um
because the the smaller your pool of
potential access points are right so you
know you've got some mid-level person
floating around you know a government
office somewhere in some target country
and you know maybe you've got lots of
options okay who do they socialize with
right who can i get access to who who
might you know be next to them you know
do they have a driver can i recruit the
driver things like that right sometimes
it's very simple but uh
putin's had a
increasingly small circle of of close
advisors and a people that he he counts
on and trusts
and part of that may be you know the
fact that that was accelerated through
the two-year pandemic where he decidedly
was shutting himself off uh because he
was he was you know paranoid like a lot
of people were about covent do you
remember when there was a guy who
suicide drove into putin's car and putin
wasn't in it
yeah that when was that that was a few
years back yeah some guy
there was oncoming traffic and he timed
it right when uh there must have been
someone communicating with him letting
him know where putin's car is but putin
wasn't even in it yeah and turned right
into oncoming traffic and used his car
as a weapon and killed the bolt of them
yeah i think killed the both of them uh
yeah i'll get you to look up when that
when that was you've seen this you've
seen the video though right yeah it was
it was a while back though it was uh
four or five years yeah
um but he's
you know people have been talking about
is is he losing his [ __ ] is he you know
is he going crazy i don't think he's i
don't think it's any of that right he's
he like gets on a table when he
negotiates and talks to people he's like
40 feet away yeah yeah and so he but and
that assessment was was clear during the
course of the pandemic he was he was
isolating himself he was being you know
very very cautious but i mean and so
maybe that had something to do with it
but he anyway point being is is it's
tough to
when you've got a a small potential well
of targets you can go after when you're
talking about recruiting somebody who's
got access to a high priority target
that's you know that's that's probably
one of the heaviest lips we've got how
do you get like how does someone get
access to like a driver do you use a
girl
um is that the best way to do it
no not really i mean you know what it's
because what you're looking to do this
is not to fall into like you know
by talking spy talking recruitment 101
but um
the movies and beach books and
everything will have you believe that
you know the best way to
hook somebody to recruit somebody is you
know blackmail or or a honey trap or
something you know there's right usually
you're working on on something else
you're not necessarily working on the
ideology but you don't want to start
from a negative basis right because
in even in normal terms in the best of
circumstances when somebody's recruited
to spy on their country to spy on on
their organization whatever it may be
there's a clock starts ticking you know
and because because things start to
decay right the person starts to decay
it's very wearing on a human right and
for a variety of reasons
um and so you know that window is going
to close at some point and it may not
end well
so you're trying to optimize that and if
you start from a negative perspective
right if you if you're you've got
someone cooperating with you because
they're blackmailing they're under the
gun here and and and they hate you and
they hate you know what they're doing
that's not what you're looking for
you're looking for a more and it sounds
weird but you're looking for more
positive so how do you approach that
like how would you get a driver to be
your buddy
well um
it's a
there's a there's a recruitment process
a cycle that you go through but uh
i hope everyone's taking notes uh but
you uh
first of all you got to know what
information you're looking for right and
so that that task gets set you know
outside the the building if you're
talking about the agency or or really
any intel service theoretically the
administration of power is setting
priority tasking so they send over this
and they say hey we need this it's a
priority target for us this information
so you look around you go okay well
who's got access to the information um
all right you build up that world and
you figure out who might be
accessible right because maybe you
you're interested in you know
a target here but he never leaves the
country you know it's a denied area
and uh
so then you find out who's got the
access the information who might be
accessible
why might they be minded to talk to you
can you create a scenario where you can
get next to them uh and then you're
looking for points of leverage right
you're really looking and that doesn't
necessarily mean you're looking to find
a negative right you're looking for
something that drives them what makes it
are their kids the most important thing
to them right do they do they have a kid
who you know needs medical attention uh
do they have a kid who they desperately
want to send away to college but they
don't have the money you know so you're
looking for something like that that may
again it sounds strange because you're
talking about recruiting somebody for
espionage but it's a positive rather
than a negative and that creates then a
longer shelf life in a sense for that
asset if that makes sense
it does make sense but it would have i
would imagine
that when you're dealing with someone
like say kim jong-un or putin or you
know some
dictator
like they they have to be prepared for
things like this right so they probably
are very cautious on who gets into their
inner circle yeah and that's that's a
counterintelligence issue right so every
you know every government out there um
you know they're worried about that
that very thing right and so i mean look
and putin
he was a kgb
officer for 15 years right yeah now
interestingly going back to putin he
he served in east germany i think for
about half a dozen years uh never really
had any exposure to the west so that's
also something when you when you're
talking about trying to assess his
mindset understand where he's coming
from part of it is look if he if he had
been exposed to the west in a much
bigger way maybe he served in new york
you know or he served in wherever you
know as a
london some place where he had more
exposure but you look at that guy and
you go he doesn't really understand how
we think right
and so that's an important thing you got
to tick that box and put that in there
when you're doing an assessment of his
personality and trying to because that's
part of understanding why he's doing
what he's doing you don't think he
understands how we think
in what way
well i know fundamentally i mean if you
look if you live in an environment right
if you
you know if you go to china you live in
wherever you know shenzhen or shanghai
or basing
and you're there for a few years you're
gonna understand the culture the mindset
much better than you know somebody who's
never lived there and is you know just
you know sitting in washington in a
think tank talking about what the
chinese regime may do next
so
it's that immersion it's that exposure
it's dealing with those people um it's
the contact that you have
um look
i'm you know i'm old enough that i
remember we uh
when the when the wall started to fall
uh when when the soviet union was
collapsing
from our perspective right as a as a
government as an intel service right we
saw that as an opportunity there's chaos
there right and what did you have you
had
intel officers like putin right kgb gru
officers who saw their world collapsing
around them because
at the time before the the the soviet
union collapsed they were living the
good life right they were the elite in a
sense right they were they were pampered
their kids were going to get the best
education they were set for life their
kids were set for life all of a sudden
the soviet union starts going to [ __ ]
right and you could see it
and you know so what did we do well we
were out there busy right working over
whatever targets we might have access to
trying to see if maybe they think you
know maybe there's another option here
maybe there's an alternative maybe i can
uh you know save myself my family
you know perhaps put aside some money by
working for the other side and that's a
natural thing to do right every service
is going to do that if there's chaos on
the other side
so
i remember you could see the confusion
and the humiliation right and the fear
in some of these guys
as this was happening and so putin went
through that same process again it's one
of those things that you do you you put
all that together to try to create this
profile of this of this individual right
so i'm not buying the talk when you know
people get on tv and go oh he's he's
going crazy he's losing his mind he said
uh
i'm not buying that there's a reason why
he's he's driving the way he is and
again he's being somewhat consistent
he's never given a [ __ ] about civilian
casualties right never bothered him
before i mean that that yeah that
situation in chechnya when they went in
there right and i mean that was that was
yeah i have to argue there was
the other side was you know was
different as well some of the chechen
separatists were and some of the [ __ ]
that they were pulling um
but at the same time he didn't care
whether he was killing civilians or you
know separatists and you know members of
their
militia military so
i i don't know i think it's it's one of
those things where i think with with
putin we've got to uh
we got to be really pragmatic here we
got to understand i don't think he's
he's not crazy he's not going to say
okay i'm in a corner
i'm gonna i'm gonna push the button and
fire off a couple of tactical nukes
right
i think what he's gotten to the point is
is you know you guys have disrespected
me this is how he thinks right you've
disrespected me [ __ ] you all i told you
i want my spirit a sphere of influence
and i don't care whether i have to break
it
i'm going to have it when you say sphere
of influence do you mean
he wants to reclaim
what is the former soviet union yeah he
said that he said he said publicly in
the past
he called uh the collapse of the soviet
union the greatest tragedy of the 20th
century that's and he's he's serious
about that he means that right
so he's not he's not [ __ ] around um
and and again
if we look at it he's being consistent
right he's been consistent over the
years
he's he's a you know he's uh he he's a
dictator he's a despot he's looking
increasingly more like you know he's
isolating himself which
you know that's that's a danger uh
in a sense to
uh
all those people around him right he's
already cut loose some of his inner
circles just over the past couple of
weeks right kazi yeah he's gotten rid of
his his way put under house arrest a
couple of his fsb uh uh senior command
why did he do that the domestic service
because he because the intel was so bad
because go again oh because of ukraine
yeah because of ukraine yeah so yeah
because of ukraine so they went in and
the assumption was and now again this is
where our intel is lacking was he given
bad intel or was he given intel and he
just chose to ignore it
but it appears as if
what he believed and what the top
military commanders some of whom have
also been let go um
or possibly reassigned i don't think
that's a good thing in in russia uh
is uh
that they were gonna they were gonna get
in there maybe within 48 hours they were
going to have control of kiev they would
be welcomed by the population in ukraine
and they would be able to establish
a puppet regime a new government i mean
they moved the previous president that
was a you know russian-backed they moved
him from russia to uh minsk
uh in preparation it appeared to move
him down to take over the government
which is in a sense batshit crazy
because he was kicked out during the
during the last revolution right by the
people 2014 yeah that was that orange
revolution that they had